more soldiers arrived at already heavily
fortified positions the show of force
coinciding with Turkey repeatedly
warning it might carry out a possible
cross-border operation its military
wants a safe zone inside the YPG
controlled area in Northeast Syria it
considers the Syrian Kurdish armed group
a threat to its national security but it
is also an ally of the United States
which has warned turkey against taking
any unilateral military action we know
that there are officially 2500 US
soldiers and nearly 220 US military
facilities in the region so in case of a
military operation there is a risk that
to matter allies - not all militaries
could come face-to-face there has been a
marked increase in u.s. army patrols
close to the border with Turkey in what
seems to be a message to its NATO ally
they have deep disagreements despite
months of discussions over the creation
of the zone turkey does not just want
the YPG to disarm and withdraw from the
border area it wants control of the zone
that's at least 30 kilometers deep and
would stretch from the Syrian town of
jarabulus to the Iraq border that would
include YPG controlled cities and towns
like kobani Tel Abyad Qamishli ein Issa
as well as members Turkey says the US
needs to end its support to the YPG
which it considers an offshoot of the
outlawed Kurdistan Workers Party or the
PKK it is also not satisfied with the
buffer zone solutions proposed by the
United States those proposals reportedly
involve a zone with the depth of 10
kilometers that excludes the main
population centers along the border YPG
supporters have held protests against a
possible Turkish takeover saying they'll
only accept an internationally enforced
zone turkey and the Syrian opposition
say areas under YPG control are
historically Arab and a proposed zone
means millions of refugees can return to
Syria
I totally dependent to partner with the
US or Russia so we can't say that it is
hard to make a prediction about Turkey's
further steps cooperation with Russia
has allowed turkey to clear the YPG from
at least 2,000 square kilometers along
its border since 2016 but Russia doesn't
seem to want turkey to increase its
influence in Syria it says any safe zone
needs the consent of the authorities in
Damascus for now it is under US control
but if US policy shifts how long that
will remain the case is unclear senator
al Jazeera because I am tempted